hello everybody
normally this is definitely - weekly
stream but it turns out actually if you
guys didn't already DLCs out and about
today so we're gonna check that out
Christa Theo Cyrus is available the
servers are up if you want to check that
out go in and get in there that's not
exactly where I wanted to be so let me
fix that there we go
alrighty so I should probably so I tried
there's a couple things I want to say
real quick off the bat I think some of
my milestones turned in on their own I
got a 306 sword
I got a 315 Actium war rig can't use
those till later that's kind of cool if
you save your milestones then that's a
thing but yeah otherwise you would have
got some prompts that unfortunately I
don't have anymore here's the first
mission of the curse of Osiris campaign
what's up bossy the cool what's up add
to the people that are coming in let me
meet this guy alrighty then we're gonna
launch this people will just have to
catch up when they catch up as such as
the way here we go hola muchachos and
which attacked it almost cost us
everything
it took a miracle to save us the
awakening of the traveler
this is our new beginning the maps are
blank the rules are gone all we know is
we must become more than what we were
this small corner of the cosmos is the
only place that is forever ours and the
universe watches us with envious eyes
we've proven we can fight threats from
beyond the stars but now there are
things stirring beneath our feet
provoked by the travelers light our war
it's just beginning okay all right Cora
giving us some backstory they're hoping
we go through vault of glass even if
it's just for a nostalgia trip hope this
is just a trailer
ominous rocks killer robots people in
mortal danger seriously aren't you tired
of this fatigue is a distraction from
our purpose as our complaints
oh I haven't begun to complain yet oh
now I'm complaining focus agura
reach for the sky big guy
[Music]
we've helped again I've got it thank you
early-bird special GU bits out this is
technically the trailer that's been
around well
Osiris
can't confirm if X buckle scale-down
blades from the darkness
[Music]
my ghost doesn't tell me
you know I can't help but notice them
even with all of reality to explore me
you keep picking two places where they
shoot at us we can't say if the VEX
succeed it's the end of everything
to see your light it is out hard for
tiger
you have to go nope not leaving you
without me there's no coming back
if I don't stop the VEX there won't be
anything to come back to I'm doing this
for the both of us
new MaxLite the 335 who will Zilla I
feel you said they fell off after the
race I kind of fell off after the raid
and the [ __ ]
wasn't that like worthwhile to do so
like we did my clan or my group that
normally runs the raid we just did it
like once just so we could finish and
get the emblem and then we never did
prestige raid ever again now there are
better incentives this time around I
think there's like ornaments and they're
addressing some of that but in terms of
like what's actually in the rate at in
terms of drops it wasn't like that
compelling to do it again I'm just kind
of like now I'm good nice raisin the bar
gives me more of a reason to play yeah
there's new exotics as well oh there's
more stuff
[Music]
[Music]
Guardian for coming my he-man Guardian
there's been a developed on mercury
strange reports from the cultists
clinging to what's left of the planet
normally I'd ignored their conspiracy
theories but one of my hidden brought me
this Dan ghost she's not dead
my name is Segura I've known her a very
long time and her guardian Osiris the
Osiris the most powerful Guardian ever
the hero of six fronts deserve Allah
before Zavala serve Allah wouldn't like
to hear you call him that
most Guardians won't even speak Osiris
his name
he was the only Vanguard commander ever
exiled from the city and the man who
taught me what it means to be a warlock
we found Sagara on Mercury and at the
same time vex activity there surged
exponentially and you think Osiris might
be involved I need to know what happened
even if the bang guard wants to forget
him
when I lost my light I didn't have
anything else I was
empty
then you came to AIA and you helped me
find my way back
I need that friend again Guardian
go to mercury takes a gira with you
the followers of Osiris the few who
remain might know what her presence
means and for now let's keep this
between us I'd hate to have to throw you
off this wall was a joke right that was
a joke I'm not afraid of I quarrel to
the people asking I'm not sure about X
Box Omar saying that it'll work in 30
minutes which is roughly around the time
that they said maintenance was gonna end
which was 10 a.m. I only did one update
it was about 6.6 gigs for me the whole
eighty eight gigs thing was to make sure
you had enough hard drive space on your
PlayStation that was including the base
game I believe so
yeah here we go I would hope that it
just launches me in the mission and it's
going to great so this will be the first
mission of the story campaign for the
DLC and then of course we just gotta get
through the campaign to get to the real
end game with destiny to the farming and
grinding there's new heroic or the
transformed mercury we got check out
don't know how to make a heroic it was a
paradise on what sea until the vex the
vex replaced the planets core with their
own machines we call it the infinite
forest an ever-expanding labyrinth of
realities no two paths are ever the same
no one has ever escaped it was a Cyrus's
obsession
so I don't think stacking engrams from
before is gonna work at least based off
previews a co-worker of mine got a new
fax that to is a sign I am brother Vance
of the followers of Osiris keeper of the
lighthouse and Oracle of the lost
prophecies so yeah I don't know that if
the engrams will work stacked the stuff
I did get that I mentioned earlier I did
get from like I think my milestones
turning in on their own so I like I have
a 315 acting in war rig already which is
good obviously but I can't equip it to
him level 22 which means you know you
got to get through parts of campaign it
is still possible to find Osiris Isis
greatest fan you got goblins that have
shields on them
kind of weird coming back to console
after playing so much PC but most of my
raid members are still on PC so will be
I'll be doing this primarily on PC ps4
for a bit
yeah little Villa
saying the game always looks so damn
great
all right you might have fumbled some of
those words but yeah I think I'm
supposed to do this
[Applause]
dynamic they're not lucky do I prefer to
play on PC ps4 is it difficult to switch
I like the fov the field of view on PC
better and I will say you know there is
definitely some more precision with so
there's that but it was weird
transitioning back and I guess at first
it's a little bit weird to get used to
PC Hawkins but once he kind of overcome
some of that yeah it's pretty pretty
good pretty solid I just had to get used
to aiming with my thumb's again I guess
which is like mouse keyboard arguably so
this see I think that is like the public
of course the police for that you know
one that were returned and the other
side of us is part of the public events
so it looks like the campaign
which I don't know maybe sadly is gonna
be so far at least in what looks like
just like not very planet where you can
do holes and stuff too
that's in the sense that like it's gonna
be like kind of like reused assets not I
wouldn't say that's me but
learn how the goblins get one shot but
uh sadly you can't get this game on
switch but good troll there
Daniel motion what's up Brandon Scobie
what a bad time to have a story
we're not dead to my overpowered for
names
here it is well I'm ready if you are
this is currently on ps4 we we decided
to do it on ps4 because most my raid
members camp is for Osiris's ghosts were
awake then maybe she could help preserve
us
you have his ghost sukira please please
bring her to me now I gotta go back
oh we got some different looking
problems they're descended problems got
like a circular head on them
fanatic
that's before anyone asks this Saul
rifle is the Lakha didn't
descendants we haven't seen these vexes
the bolt of glass to throw back I
haven't seen him like this though didn't
look like this in the vault of glass
that harpy definitely to use like a
reverse flower petal
where's baller horn I don't know that's
a good question I'd like to know so this
is all part of the the huge her or
decline her or the huge public event
raises are you able to get the expansion
after the release date because I can't
wait for a whole year to get close I
mean you can get it whenever after if
you want it usually becomes cheaper
usually like a year later what will
happen as well
they have like that taking king version
or that complete edition that'll have
like everything up to whatever you're
selling at that time
you only want a superbike feel like he's
gotta be a big guy
it's cannon fodder
get on pcj I'll be there I know you guys
would do that PC I'll get back on the PC
after I kind of do my initial wave here
on console as mentioned what's my raid
members are on consoles that's as we all
know that
rate is really what
main kind of
big boy
oh so there is a new Engram you brighten
grams called them illuminated in German
but yeah the old brightened groundwork
kind of curious if there's an an
illuminated exotic Engram which would
then different time lines are converging
on Merc you kind of stop you had you
know getting to their old place that's
for sure
okay so that joke right there was the
fact that you used to have to die no to
get to the lighthouse which is where
we're at this looks really cool i think
i've seen some concept art of this but I
don't know what I would have done if
Osiris had intentionally Scrolls in
return
the followers of Osiris can help you
revive his ghost we have a qualm temple
on earth takes longer to these
coordinates okay I will notify the
followers that you are coming now that
the lighthouse is safe we can prepare
for Osiris's return all of the lost
prophecies are coming to pass I'm
finally going to meet Osiris
this is cool okay legendary engrams are
still the same so that's good for us
dan that's really cool like say what
people like people can say whatever they
want but that there is some really cool
[ __ ] in destiny
alright I've unlocked mercury as a
landing zone so you just got to do the
first mission to do that when is he
gonna time-travel that's a good question
Trevon Brown I don't know I'm pretty
sure this DLC is mainly about
time-traveling though you'll see
different area error eras of the
lighthouse oh so let's see so there's a
new gift from tests complete mission a
deadly trial in etz so it looks like
what we need to do next and of course
all our milestones are there is the rate
layer there yet no red layer is not
there yet I guess it's going there
here's the new rate 300 so are we done
with Mercury okay so mercury is now like
a planet with a hook there's a public
event it's gonna be there in four
minutes I guess we'll just keep doing
story oh there's a story machine right
there I guess we're going to the ddz for
whatever reason can we see the ornaments
[ __ ] I can try
do you guys want me to go to the tower I
can go to the tower instead to check out
the the Ingram you guys want me to do
that instead I mean we can possibly fly
somewhere else maybe or I'd have to swap
characters here well do um well finish
the mission and then we'll go we'll go
to the tower and see if there's a
ornaments and whatnot I'm also probably
just gonna pop a lot of the legendary
engrams cuz they're in my way
essentially so there's a new writing
Graham illuminated one I stocked all my
treasure maps to try to get myself
better chances at exotics I don't know
if that's going to work so I can either
do this mission or I can go to the tower
it's really weird that we're I mean it's
not that weird wanted to be on Mercury
more but we'll see what happens here
yeah the vendors are gonna be selling
gear too from now on I think it's a
little bit more expensive now to buy
things from the planetary people it's
gonna cost more tokens but it's also I
think tokens dropped more frequently so
that's kind of the reason why it's more
expensive the coordinates brother Vance
gave us are just beyond the village
Hawthorne Scouts surveyed that area in
the red war there's no temple there just
an old radio tower have a little faith
menorah
huh never looked at that painting before
oh hello boy
why would you guys use your own vehicles
so are the followers all as passionate
as brother Vance
you mean fanatical yes they follow the
idea of Osiris they do not know the man
that I did but they're our best chance
to revive sadirah some cult action
clearly this was meant to be a vehicular
level
to many like a week mom's for it not to
be
I just feel like the Walker today
you guys a fan of the vehicle gameplay I
think it's fine I guess it's better to
have it in single-player though I never
liked
all right
but people want to see the tower
I feel bad for any critic Osiris culture
not to be Scientology trial where's Tom
Cruise
it's a trap
cool
and I was gonna be here than I
oh it does do the grenade thing sweet
we shot a flare they know I'm here it's
just a radio tower and the fall of got
here first that some grenades
oh the question - these are the squeeze
higher light
you have to imagine getting to like
three tens got to be like easier
I think you're not my type
oh you're kind of cool is there's Jam
things
[Music]
feel like we gotta go up right
wrong
[Music]
right where they want me I guess
[Music]
followers were too late oh that's what
he meant
did you guys kill yourselves is that
what happened like that way guy episode
where meg shows up to like a cult party
on the way look we've got right now
Osiris is in over his head as usual I
need to wait where are we who are you oh
never mind we've got to get to mercury
and don't worry about sharing right now
back okay I actually like this goes
better can we keep Segura Steven
Gonzales so bad hmm what does that mean
we used to have a guy named Steve Nannes
all as he was in our raid crew our old
raid crew I doubt that's you Steve but
so Jim I don't think you heard me
earlier but there's a new bride in
Graham so I think I Skyped that to you
guys though you sassy robot voice hope
she's not as annoying as last I don't
know I think she's okay right now all
right
the lighthouse saw something in the
infinite forest and it terrified him
nothing terrifies him we need to find
trouble you'll never find your way out I
know I can do it
Osiris is in there protecting the rest
of us from the vex he needs us he needs
me and we're going to find him yeah wish
it we're going through like worms okay
that's cool
hopefully I don't fail that platforming
put on my rocket boots more jump cool
just like some weird part of the vault
of glass that like is hidden back
entrance
all right
it's weird their song it's back there by
Osiris has adapted some of the
technology of the forest to his own
purposes we're going to run into his
reflections their copies of himself made
so he can explore multiple pathways at
once
sounds like our Lord's dad Cyrus seemed
like an egomaniac but don't worry he is
negative uh sorry there is has to be
here somewhere
don't really jump into that Europe you
should be you brought someone new with
you
who Oh him is he's a friend of I Korres
well I guess we're jump in this way
send word to get rise whoa hologram guys
Cyrus sent you away for your own safety
your presence here puts everything at
risk well guess what he needs me
are we the key to the puzzle the key to
the puzzle so what's this red layer
about I'm not sure yet it's like a
shorter version of a raid it's almost
too late
and what do they mean too late
something must have gone wrong where's
the real Osiris you cannot go to
what what did you find what's so bad but
it could scare Osiris behold the
infinite forest planet size predictions
simulating trillions of realities in
parallel all geared towards a single
thanks purpose
keep going with it you'll see the VEX
are simulating reality route force in
the future and before you ask everything
in here is real and absolutely
really
oh yeah
Shakira the ghost oh it's a door to
sometimes the forest blocks a path
eliminate the demon controlling the
local simulation and the door should
open
we're fighting demons oh there's more
than one demon
let's just miss that so that doesn't
bother you guys
keep hearing something like whining up
I like daemon like thanks for the tip
there Wheatley
[Music]
Wow guys drop some loot
[Music]
so first wing of allows last region rage
is why Oh Ella fire
I guess we're going down
all right and back into I don't know
what that is but I guess we're going
into it then we already do this time
travel
sort of we got some different like no
man's sky now first show me where oh
there's no mascot Curie untold centuries
ago
here they come here the VEX planted the
seed that became the infinite forest
it's mine anak tease kETK news
Panoptix has a single purpose we shape
reality and only the vex all this
started with a single vex right a lot of
single guardian
now I see why he's made so many new
reflections
yes we've tried and failed even our best
efforts only slow it
we got me there court jester X yellow
Zilla I am liking the campaign so my
guardian just like all the prettiness of
it we got falling now with the ship now
many things in set in motion Cyrus Rose
the most and they sent him away
exile the future
oh no Cyrus a road people didn't believe
in what he was saying
excuse me again I get those rapid-fire
sneeze attacks like where it's always
more than one we yeah we kind of time we
time traveled there to a mercury-free
like vex arriving which is kind of cool
it looked really nice it kind of looked
like a no-man's guy kind of thing
axes
gotta say my accuracy is much better in
the morning I haven't checked the Blues
actually let's take a look nope $2.99 so
far oh they just disappear like this is
like a well he's like a simulation
it
all right are we gonna run into cabal
what's new max power level 335 with mods
so 330 without Mustafar it could be the
possible future DLC faction but I'm
alright we're going to the future now
guys this is what happens if the Dex
take over I guess oh this is the
lighthouse
sun's warmth is gone or life loss
that was before you
Hill on the key you can stop this
every timeline with track leads here we
must destroy conductors to prevent this
dark future
what I got to do for that headcount got
their [ __ ] not these whoa
does that mean
what do you want me to go oh I shouldn't
have ran backwards
I thought I was gonna fight him together
all of us you me Osiris I Cora if we
don't stop thanks wheelie you've seen
what happens
so Wheatley saying if you infuse the
level 21 into it level 20 beer the
existing gear will then require a level
21 so make sure your level first you
just left where's the cyrus in trouble
we all are
I'll explain everything on our way back
to the city
so it looks like there's like a what are
the one of those things called
God I'm trying to think of the enemy
type that that guy is but he has arms
instead on top of the fact that uh
trying to think of the enemy type and I
can't for the life of me all right well
at least we get to go to the tower which
is good
we better fight angel batam battle mecha
at some point yeah I'm pretty sure
that's gonna be the campaign boss
yeah but hopefully you guys having fun
thanks for hanging out with me
on destiny dlc destiny la acción it's
crazy like you guys all sent it at the
same time hydra thank you
it's like a modified hydra that has like
hands just like weird to even think of
but yeah we're gonna have a bunch of you
know stuff come out as the time as time
goes by we'll try to figure out how to
do the heroic public event that's on
Mercury and not open the director
there's a way to trigger it this is a
this whole thing is a public event it
starts here you gotta do stuff here then
I go here then go here then you come
back to here the planet actually doesn't
look that big I know
a little bit worried something all right
let's take a look at some of the stuff
you guys wanted to take a look at I
don't want to crap I gotta let me go get
rid of some oh so here's the new Ingram
here we can preview it
you got the selfie
I kind of want that just because it's
like the the Tonti kind of thing you can
be a sweeper bot you want to be that
doesn't seem
that great
yes oh whoa got some crazy-looking ships
that looks pretty cool it's just a
modified version obviously but still
nice to have the detail there most guys
oh this week we got I have a cyrus
ornament ooh that was cool
I'm guessing that's four flame heart the
the new trace rifle woojae Jess I want
Jade rabbit so bad I'm assuming this is
for Jade rabbit here's the Jade rabbit
skin that's the exotic I kind of want
the most is one of my favorites oh wow
oh there's ornaments here's here's a
Titan ornament for the chest the lava is
slowly flowing and it's kind of like a
volcano unless they buff solar I don't
see myself buying that chest that techno
scarab oh [ __ ] is this a helm this might
be that crazy home yeah it looks like a
beetle that doesn't look that cool
Oh what the hell is this oh you can have
a reflection as a transmat that's pretty
sick is this hit or [ __ ] so far says
hell of a mouse I'm liking the campaign
so far but you know you have to judge
the camp like the expansion on a whole
and I don't know how big that one planet
is how big mercury is it doesn't seem
that big because it looks as big as the
public event from just a map overlay
that's one of those ghosts here's an oh
that's kind of cool Cosmo shale so yeah
those are some of the ornaments I'm sure
on other characters we can we can check
out some other characters later I'll
look at some of these shaders here's a
mercury vex Chrome
no idea what this is gonna look like
that looks but ugly never been a fan of
brown but that could you know what that
kind of has that old Gundam look like
those uh oh no thanks thanks to this
desert of gold and yeah these are yeah I
guess I could have previewed the
sparrows but I'm gonna rip somebody's
purple engrams like you're gonna unload
them since they're not really doing
anything
all right that's old that's old that's
old
hold all right all those wet all those
engrams were old oh that was master
Rahul selling legendary engrams I think
let me just blow that stuff up real
quick sorry guys
you know housekeeping one of the biggest
things you got to do I'm almost full on
glimmer or two so we need to definitely
spend on blue mods blue mods now have a
chance I believe of dropping mod parts
which is good on level 21 that's good
alrighty let's go buy some do to us that
was laggy though when I was blowing
those up for whatever reason Eric did
you save all the ones they don't turn
into DLC yes I just realized that but
thank you I did it just as a distant
place anyways because I had it figured
why not
so what else do oh here let's take a
look at what Rahul how much that thing
is from Rahul it sounds selling we're
bigger than man legendary Engram yep so
you can buy it at legendary engrams from
him 300 power at 25 shards per
so it's a boy oh he's got stuff you can
iron armor ornaments now that you can
buy you got a complete objectives on
your way god why can't those rookies in
the crucible be more like you see they
say claim crucible reward engrams during
season two rewards claimed okay so uh
yeah defeat enemies in the crucible
during season two there's a lot - so you
got killed 250
oh wait can preview these for you guys
sorry I don't notice the big difference
most of the ornaments in the past had
like a glow or something to him this is
the arm plates again no particular glow
this one needs 25 challenges
this is milestones I don't see any glow
to the this oh the feathers are cool
though it's got that red with grey kind
of tints for the feathers so far that's
probably the coolest looking thing and
the helm looks ugly oh sorry let me sew
the helm you need matches one this is
five milestones over so this is gonna
take the longest and of course it looks
the coolest so let's go take a look at
Vanguard
really wish we had some new enemy types
seeing the same tree is disheartening
yeah I agree
take shelter so this is the easiest one
to get I mean I could turn that in right
now but hold off just look better than
its a modified version
I'm guessing there's gonna be like
faction ornaments to guess that close a
little bit this one is based off strikes
[Music]
yeah so that's the swallow you know all
us that would sell stuff I doubt it
I think I'm almost level 22 which is
good yeah and it does appear that all my
milestones turned in on their own
I had milestones from last week that's
why you have any treasure chests oh it's
not there right oh he's here
what the hell a rock Jarl welcome back
oh you could buy the dead orbit stuff
which obviously won't matter until that
barely looks different
like am I crazy like these barely look
different right like I kind of miss
destiny one ornaments I like the old
ornaments where like [ __ ] glowed this is
like very minor to me I mean like
obviously it's something to do and
that's that's cool but old ornaments at
like enhanced like raid armor or like
you know the iron Lord stuff was really
cool come to help us sorry I haven't
been doing the sashes huh yeah it kind
of look clean the best looking armor is
new monarchy though so this has like
that dot pattern
I guess that's that's the ornament so
you get a little dot pattern
yeah
guess that's alright I'm gonna go check
out any monarchy because we gotta go
talk to Ike hora anyways
I think you buy it separately gesture
eighty-four gesture but it cost more if
you don't just buy this season I think
the season packs like 35 whereas if you
buy this individually probably $19.99
[Music]
I don't know why future were called
ornament is white Bob but that's what it
is and we're on our way check out videos
inventory and then to check out what the
next story mission is for my Cora
what's up
sorry
the cult has been betrayed I guess you
could say that back from the while its
Guardian all right meanwhile our key set
should look pretty good though
ooh look at that red gold the gold line
maybe I have to defect and Goni monarchy
that is probably been the coolest Titan
sash oh boy
Wow why is this so much better-looking
holy crap
Titan armor looks sick dude look at
these lions
damn I might have to go
I might have to Konya monarchy man the
Helms roughly the same but damn those
those dis dis is probably the coolest
right here holy crap look at that lion
yeah we goin we got he monarchy when the
faction Wars come back no doubt about
that kind of feels bad man betraying
trading my cause the dead orbit cause
but man new monarchy holy smokes whoever
shoutouts to ever get their set of stuff
turning any in any of my clan oh let's
see what the clan in grant was what do
you need maybe it'll scale
oh it's 306 yeah I would if you have
those guys I would save them and turn
those in later
kind of wish are getting raided not
after the red wool last week so that we
could have got an extra day these knew
they'd have a schematic
oh cool she's giving me something all
right oh god what if we screw this up
only one place they could possibly store
that much I got positive outlook a
million on Io it's like an online auto
rifle
accurized rounds or armor-piercing and
kill clipped okay then you got living
memory hand cannon it's got extended mag
or tactical mag
grape good ol grave-robber how's this
compared to well it doesn't
well this reloads for you at five you it
now if I view about the same but why
would you not just use better Devils
then alright then you have eternal blaze
on jazz increase movement speed while
aiming down the sight appended mag
increase means design or steady rounds I
don't like any of these options really
think they're all kind of met it's
probably gonna be this this Auto rifle
for me unless this is better
Scott oh you run faster to you what you
guys think 305 is not improvement this
is from story
do I want to scout oh they're not modded
I guess that's true good three three ten
it so what I definitely want to scout
then could alright that's tough actually
it's definitely gonna be auto or Scout I
guess lot of range
let's see how it compares to aerials
it's got more range more stability I
don't know man I don't know what to take
I think I'm just gonna take the scout
rifle I can always do the missions over
so whatever my powers to do five so I
could technically infuse midnight with
the blaze blaze on to get to 310 Yolo
for the stream all right we got three
ten midnight didn't really help us my
level 22 no this help that's that was a
non modded oh yeah that's the I'm 305
with mods
I'm gonna go pop the New Brighton grams
and then I guess we must just have a
random story new story mission they just
turned in that quest the things that
we're dropping were like less than 300
though blues and stuff what's up Jeff in
I should buy clear my post of these
purple engrams to know the towers feels
like oh I have a 300 Wow why do I have
to 300 this is stuff from last week
so these milestone stuff is from last
week the luminous stuff and then I've
gotten oh so some of the purples that
were dropping in the world or 3:05 as
well so we should probably decrypt those
[Music]
that's kind of cool
well tighten let's see what we have
alright so maybe we can get some new
legendaries or not this one these lower
tier one the one have it but so we have
a 303 and a 305 so let's see what the
303 is two helmets and the 305 is a
glove it's the old stuff though but in
theory that's a 305 with no mod so right
yeah so we can we can mod we can we can
definitely power up here sequins Oh what
the hell
oh it's cuz the ornament
I'll put it on these gloves yeah I kind
of don't care right now I'm sure we'll
get way more stuff later so three oh so
now we're three ten there's over 306
just put in the skull for it for now no
it's a waste we got a couple more
engrams so I might as well I mean those
luminous engrams aren't gonna turn
higher sadly so might as well just turn
them anyway but if you sat if you stack
your milestones from last week oh there
you go it gave me a new weapon too well
and for some reason it's giving me eat
easy stuff oh we got some new boots new
exotics that is definitely a new exotic
whoa those look kind of crazy what the
hell is the ability on them okay grants
an over shield while sprinting at full
health with seismic strike hammer strike
or shield bash oh wow so you get
juggernaut so this is juggernaut then
right hello Dustin dang that's cool give
me one second guys
[Music]
all right so that's kind of cool
can't use those until level 20 - it
appears so yeah if you had luminous
engrams last week hopefully you got
lucky and got some stuff I got
technically a 315 war rig and then I got
those boots at like this probably still
doesn't give the exotic engrams seem
like they're still not giving new stuff
so yeah I'm almost 22 damn I should've
popped that home into into the skull for
it here's a new uh sidearm swift
solstice it's kind of a reskin but you
can tell us the new stuff because it has
that typical oso I could have picked
this hand cannon earlier we just got
that keep that for now this is new 306
chests with no mods so we'll just put it
into our chest right now
although I'm gonna have a 315
yeah whatever that's one can't be
overthinking this stuff Oh
got any Titan sash to put it into our
dead orbits
yeah you definitely want to try - we
definitely want to try to level up here
so that our purple drops as we're
playing our higher light [ __ ] it's a
sidearm oh we got a 306 annual stage
it's gonna be higher actually oh no the
game's smart enough to pick what my eyes
is sans the exotic sorry guys sorry
we're doing something I'm very curious
all right with 308 well get there though
okay
sorry oh you know I screwed that up
[Music]
don't know where my uncle finds these
things
I screwed that one that's why I'm always
good to see you Guardian so here's the
new stuff that she's given us so let's
see if we get anything good hey feels
bad
we got an arrow Hawk and with there's a
new transmat this is old stuff I'm
getting rid of the old stuff sorry guys
oh we got a horse t at least we got
golden trace that's fine alright so
here's another illuminated Ingram I'm
gonna kind of let that screen go away
come on Sophie it's 35 for both
expansions
oh nice this is a faster spawning thing
so that's good I can give that to one of
my other characters I don't know if I
have three of them three fast spawning
all right whatever
cool all right let's keep doing the
story we leveled up a bit that's a 308
it's nice to have been shot you got a
160 fast one yeah so my time has the 160
fastball unluckily I think some of my
other characters don't have even a fast
spawn so even 150 fast one would be good
okay you know what I've been screwing up
guys we got to put a turning these on Oh
actually it's just strikes public events
a crucible though whoops
whatever it's fine
dang I should have took that auto-rifle
now in hindsight because I could be out
at 3:10
yeah sadly inventory size didn't get
larger nor did we get more vault space
Ypres more space for mods and shaders in
[Music]
do not disagree with that
all right we're doing the we're gonna go
to the pier median again why
kind of wish they would let you wear
more than two exotics I mean yeah it's
hard to say part of me feels like yeah
part of me feels like no are you sure
there's a map of the infinite forest
here
if the vex are trying to reshape the
future the pyramidion this part of the
plan has to be here only because the
exotics aren't as strong as they used to
be so it's like I don't feel like it's
as big of a deal if like everyone take a
knee
I know a trick with that country so you
guys definitely want to hold off your
milestones turning in this week as long
as you can just so you get the highest
gear because that does follow your light
advice would need to hold off high night
also to hold off on your night balls
raids like that I don't actually think
it's gonna be that hard to do this
I took maybe two weeks at most maybe a
week maybe English people think we've
done this week but it's only on Mercury
to my knowledge Cyrus was saying back
then it wasn't just his prophecies also
there should be the dawning should be
coming this one banner will be this one
faction rally so this whole month no
idea what really released either yet I
see now I so we do want
legendaries to drop right now because
they seem to be dropping higher than for
at least 3 or 5 vo 305 303 ok this
something
[Applause]
that was weird
that could run consular so we want a
level right so you say
Arai we're point to
technically the chess court I was right
my scans showed the pyramidion does
receive data from the forest but then my
home can access what happens
okay we're 309 now those are ugly
we need a shader them what does that
look like that looks much much more
desirable than these rusty looking boots
oh so I can't yeah I don't have the
reverse angle of this but I guess I have
juggernaut yeah like I have an over
shield and I guess since I got a kill it
only took half of my melee which is kind
of cool those boots I know right pretty
cool but m'kay asides were in I can't be
you all at work but that was not what
the perk was before so there's a bunch
of exotics that are kind of making their
return Jade rabbit still what I really
want and they probably have different
like modifiers so we got to see what
those are
Xbox servers are up says Connor French
nice thank you for that information if
you guys were waiting on Xbox I hope you
guys have some fun
mu
populations kind of weird not having
excuse me the lasers it takes a while
for the overshield to spin up the system
it's only while you're charging here's a
secret no one has ever lived up to a
Cyrus's reputation not even Osiris
dude I wonder how good that is in PvP
though
but you can see like I don't know though
cuz the thing is you're not taking that
much damage when your shoulder parking
generally and the thing is shoulder
charge doesn't 1-shot anymore so it's
kind of like I don't know what's the
point
how long are you going for at eight till
the end of the campaign I'm not sure
about that
I think Darren was telling me that
him and Cali were able to get through
the most of the campaign in their life
three showers but they kind of ran
through a lot of stuff so
my overshield whoa-ohh yet that full
health oh thank you alright
oh we go down a lot faster
is this the old strike yeah this is the
pyramidion we're just going back to get
the infinite forces somewhere nearby
but the VEX must be cloaking it
how we were close to the end I don't
think so
hard to say I'm not positive we've only
done like three or four where maybe this
one's a third
I haven't seen that big guy again
hi dear without hands
finalize it
okay
there we go also we haven't totally
liked unlock the mercury lighthouse yet
because that's supposed to be a social
space star of course the map wasn't in
here yes you can enjoy destiny too
without buying the expansion pack or
Tonto the only thing is now that the
expansion is out you'll just be locked
out of doing these activities so
unfortunately if you're trying to do any
of the DLC content you won't be able to
do that obviously so alright oops so
we're going to mercury it sounds like to
do the next story mission which is tree
of possibilities
Dustin dang already wants the next DLC
which is more Seva related maybe they'll
bring back sleeper simulant that'd be
kind of cool see who's playing we got on
we got yep
got some folks playing I'm currently the
highest light feels good feels good man
it feels good our blues are dropping a
301 non modded which means I should keep
that maybe I don't know I can also just
infuse my chest maybe 315 I guess I
don't really use rig that that often
rigs pretty good if you use auto rifles
but I like some of the other stuff some
people thought speculated that maybe
homeless a14 might be back but that one
feels weird
I don't want them to bus
that mission that kind of want them to
buck you know either Sentinel or hammers
solar because I don't know double pulse
grenade right now is like too good so I
won't stop using that until they fix it
the new cap is 335 long lay orally if
you count mods 330 without mods so
currently have 309 so that's pretty cool
Bob saying full clans can now queue as
guides for a guided game survivors from
the all-mighty survivors huh let's
finish the job
so we got cabal now
just think I got turrets
unless something changes I think it is
inverted spire this
let's get to that patrician I'm more
filling but that information was based
off of the old 2:00 a.m. reset the new
resets will be at 9:00 a.m. on pizza
Pacific time
ma'am
oh okay
but anyway
like white armor all right I am like out
of primary that's fine
okay
find another gateway and I can get us to
the note oh I'll find another gateway so
I guess this is how they kind of make
the planet seem bigger because the
actual planet itself is not that big but
I guess if you're going through to the
infinite force that's how they kind of
get extra T's - even if he makes a
million copies of himself I don't think
I'll find it
that's the kind of dog I want
they're no new crucible set I haven't
seen it yet Connor
there are crucible ornaments
stoner rafter not happy that DLC is
already out citing greed
I was gonna play regardless but I am
obsessed enough and I like the game
guess we in a way and part of the
problem
like I guess my money
the ornaments didn't look that
cool except for new monarchies and upset
Elly's that is what I'm getting for sure
unless I that stuff looks really amazing
- which is possible
difficulties certainly get a little
harder
as much stuff I have the
I guess you could skip all this but
if the infinity of force changes every
time it doesn't need to be that big
just like procedural though probably but
not truly it's not I think they came out
and said it's not actually procedurally
generated but I bet there's enough tile
sets that it's like different each time
right
how many very permutations are as a
mystery
I guess could go just double AR and
where the actor rigs but people want to
see the exact the thing is I feel like
yeah in terms of deals in the info
leaking yeah I did week earlier the
thing is how much of it is actually the
developer versus the publisher in terms
of like then winding them too deep like
DLC content you know like I think milady
I guess from a developer side like they
need to obviously sell more stuff
I guess you could also argue though that
like you could in theory with the micro
transactions that are in the game that
are cosmetic the hope would be that
maybe that amount of money would be
enough to kind of pay the way for actual
content in the game but publishers are
gonna get what they want as long as it
doesn't get bad enough where it's like I
hate using battlefront 2 as an example
but that is the kind of a big big issue
this year in terms of like micro
transactions as long as it doesn't
affect my game I guess I'm not that mad
but could also argue that the fact that
it's you gotta pay to get more content
out of games but I spent like I don't
hundreds of hours with just the flavor
definitely not a problem for me but I
could see that being a problem for
Bob stuck his ps4 in rest mode so that
he'll download the update while he's at
work yeah I left my home ps4 on rest
hopefully this is a combat loop a
simulation of the recent past when the
Cabal attacked mercury the VEX must be
testing alternative outcomes
like I'm surprised
we're not done to campaign but it would
have been kind of cool to have like a
way that changes like every week do the
infinite forest and you're just going
through different areas like maybe
there's like a water depending on the
areas you're going through like it gives
you a new boss or three bosses until
it's like the last one but I guess in a
way you could argue that's like prison
at all these great layers aren't out yet
so I can't really judge I'm a little sad
that there isn't oh wow I got to use the
spare
I feel like I couldn't made that good
jump but alright you say so
oh cool
an assault rifle
stop shooting me
does anyone in chat has anyone done the
it's curious if any of y'all move I have
this feeling it's like you gotta shoot
skeet shoot
that's Kishu where you guys shoot the
harpies then you jump over there's like
three on each side I don't know if
that's it
that seems kind of too easy though I
guess why do blue engrams sleep here why
I have colorblind mode on I don't really
like the bass games color scheme I guess
personally
that's must know we're after the map
they're redirecting the Cabal to destroy
it we have to hurry
and of
why isn't there rave in there it was
huge
whatever that is oh that's the thing
that we thought that I was making fun of
that was like looks like the Death Star
curious to how worthwhile the heroic
rights would be now that that's back in
the game as well also wondering if
there's like a soft cap for a loved one
where do we hit that I didn't come party
level morning
all right in ground
the ship is not there
you like you anymore that I'm guessing
that in ground someone in that video
look at that ahead of us that has to be
the map the infinite forest is a
doomsday machine but when you see over
this it's almost beautiful
that Minotaur is going to talk
oh I just killed him Oh what is this
laser [ __ ]
I don't get it it's like a war between
the Cabal and the freaking mechs
I wasted my sister - I got baby where's
that guy go
they all die they like all the boss guys
time or did you just teleport somewhere
else
now you're back oh you've got different
gun whoa okay
new gun new enemy gun oh okay it pushes
you against the wall not cool
stop oh that's such a bad idea to go
through the laser
alright this level is kind of cool you
know it's a bunch of laser beams you
gotta avoid while fighting
why not hurt them poor [ __ ] yeah
got some platforming
[Music]
don't walk away
[Music]
I should have sorted everyone getting
yeah ripped first death I didn't see
that coming
what's up Roy regen nation are you
scanning you mean that map
there are vex minds are necessary the
trick you up for a hunting expedition no
I'm not I'm just sure your dog here
fetching fetching what you need oh you
gotta legend no you grin from beating
that mission though at least there's
that let's check out what those 311 and
305 so finishing that one gave me a 311
so you know I guess the higher you are
the better it's gonna be for you in
terms of drops from missions as well
how's the expansion as asking Stephen kW
it's okay so far that mission was kind
of cool I like that now we got good
missus because apparently our ghost
doesn't have enough processing power so
there's that does that mean III feel
like that means I have to ultimately go
back to that map area because maybe by
that I can get the map
I probably should be decrypting that
stuff though huh the only thing that's
not hires my helm yeah I even need a
white no I'd only get to 306
whoa this is
or I just never noticed it before okay
I'm burning burning
okay okay just get to the quest I don't
know why I don't remember those
platforms burning though that was a pre
dlc adventure ah I guess it just looks
different than what I remember though I
haven't had that mission in a long time
it's getting hot with this hat um that
take it off yeah I remember them burning
now yeah yeah it looked different though
the fire whatever it looked like it was
white that class effects mine should
provide the processing power just
passing by as the trash gotta get back
to real life I don't think it's trash
but if you weren't that into destiny I
think it's hard to convince people that
like hey you should get back in because
of the dlc i think that if you're like
destiny you're gonna keep playing there
definitely adding some good quality of
life stuff you can get heroic strikes
back
you're gonna have master work weapons
which will allow us to reforge they're
doing some better stuff with the in
terms of the economy you'll actually be
able to spend legendary shards so
there's like enhancement and the story
so far has been pretty interesting
there's some levels better than others
so yeah I know
so base it on that you can kind of make
a decision maybe maybe not but as a fan
of destiny I think it's a crap well
Corrine Tom how are you
you do not heart me go D that's a higher
do you want me to go to the tree I'm so
confused right now
now it's telling me this way
[Music]
that's just below okay well I guess
there are bad guys down
down right
makes all the sense of the world now I
think we're on the right track
damn caves
your voice sounds really familiar for
the goes
what if it's just like the failsafe
voice actor but she's just doing
something slightly different
I got slightly different voice
I got the Prometheus lens what is that
is that a weapon or a armor if you want
to send me a screenshot of that that'd
be cool
it's the girl from Deadpool make his
girlfriend or
out of the picture
you get that random one
Xbox one did get the 4k updates other
Pro there pro support in this as well I
haven't tested that though I'm playing
on a normal piece war when beast
Riyadh's morena
a car in his was Bob Dylan says to my
energy just slot just inspects go say
get alright one second guys nice
Prometheus lens guys kills with this
weapon returning a fraction that ammo
use the magazine alright far as solar
trace beam all looks pretty cool the
little like diamond in the middle look
at the lower yeah it looks pretty cool
screenshot that oops
oh I mean they do that all right all
right cool thanks for that go Sagan if
you guys get any new exotics tell me try
to get a post together with as many as
you can
that's pretty clear though did you get
that from like just an exotic in Graham
I just need to the look there's a chest
there should work cold heart I had like
never used until Calais and then once I
started using black I didn't I actually
never stop using coal part hundred
percent I don't know I just wasn't that
fun to me to hold down I guess
oh and Nara from fireflies what
gentleman says exotic and graham from a
public event oh nice I get my flash
point first to level up a bit okay I got
you
that's cool I'm glad you got a new
exotic though
because we're all you know like the
table still has the oh oh but does
anyone know if that one patches in where
you get the less dupes or whatever or no
more dupes the less you that makes a
difference in terms of like getting
yeah I think heroic public event farming
is probably still gonna be the fastest
way to get exotic engrams
and I'm not even sure doing the mercury
ones like that worth it because of like
how much time it actually takes to
finish it which is like the sad part of
like the whole thing right is that
you're always gonna do well I want say
you're always but like what's the time
people are gonna do what's most
efficient what's the most efficient it's
like not do that one probably it's my
guess and from what I've seen like in
terms of like video like even for us
when we finish event or the sorry the
public event it just doesn't give you
that much of an over reward
I hear you
it's platforms
that's all
have you something bad right
what was I damn for idea
sorry if you got that we're usually bad
people when they're like really hyper
offensive or talks it's just the trick
I'm out of ideas here what if the answer
lies in the past great you found the
code that created penalties you could
use the infinite forest against the vex
yes we go back to the moment that led to
Panoptix one time forward and use that
data to find its location in the present
oh that's good I Cora Osiris level good
you know you're not the same I Cora I
remember you're better
sounds like we're going to the past
[Music]
where the milestones this week
splash point
we use the infinite forest against the
vex or I'm calculating where to send us
Centauri is far because finding a
simulation of the right
I'm curious what the new strike I tried
not to watch too much stuff are you
colorblind a little no I just like the
color blind they're most vulnerable here
this simulation will be well defended
the point in history will you invent a
reality engine I just bought the
coordinates for the exhaust yourself
yeah I actually looked at it in the
store but thank you really
the bad that I gave up on destiny two
before the personality nope not at all
I could see that it's kind of tough like
once you beat the rate it's kind of like
one of those things
assuming you even wanted to keep the
regular duties arrayed after you beat it
there isn't much reason to go back in
unless you just wanted to complete like
the set of armor or for me it's more of
having the experience of hanging out
so I use it for that and we do have I
played with some of those guys since
destiny one like doing Baltic last time
I sucked two friends in that my main
core group for that raid and then a
couple that we picked up kind of we're
like met up on the way to blow or taking
King or House of wolves so it's it's
more of like a tradition now for me with
you
maybe that's what a lot of people don't
pay for I mean like in the same way you
can say that about games like World of
Warcraft so that's my location but I
could see why I keep it at a stop I
still think the shooting mechanics are
really great stuff I enjoy I guess
what a [ __ ] oh it's actually quite fun
on PC - I think it feels actually a
little bit better on PC because we have
more fishes precision but because a lot
of my poor people rating friends console
or the stand console not like we saying
they take a break before the dlc comes
out yeah that's a pretty smart idea so
so long if I remind you all the fun you
had
because other than that like you're just
basically like waiting for events kind
of happen and they play just during
those events they do a pretty good job
of having events later at least every
other week assuming you're not just good
for milestone higher looking for
I didn't complete the raid because of
the toxic people that you file in Iowa
and then I went flawless like four times
like flawless Krauss yeah I mean like
writing stuff if you need a whole group
but uh think Bob said that guy two games
might be a little bit better
[Music]
oh no I think that if you haven't done
the Ray that's still worth doing it's
not my favorite raid by my third
favorite raid I think both the glass no
actually it's a process the wrath of
machines is pretty good I didn't like
this amber I guess what I'm saying
when this is all over I might actually
miss being your ghost just felt like
just a little this raid was more about
doing puzzles and things like that not
somewhat about shooting stuff I like to
call up some time though and download
the algorithm before the VEX create the
infinite forest this area really
switching up some gameplay here just a
little bit bored of using the hand game
update 1.2 yep gives for pro support
that's box one for it I mean I did
finally get a 4k TV I just need to
acquire a pronoun for my house check out
what destiny looks like okay all we can
do is fight our way in be unpredictable
[Music]
maybe the infinite force it's pretty
cool I think it could open this open
some stuff up for them down the road
like what they can do to add to the game
keep things fresh the different
so let's me what this DLC does it come
with a raid no unfortunately there's no
raid in this one there is something
called a raid layer which is also on the
world eater it's a shorter rate like
experience but still has like raid
elements and still six people so
[Music]
romantic oh there's a lot of guys
he sent me to chase my pool
hold on one sec
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I may die
I realize suppers gonna spawn behind
them dangerous
[Music]
make it we're in the lighthouse
we're in let's get to the top and find
that algorithm
that's weird
this one
Nally now please try to mindful of
trying to self-promote
really here for that but I appreciate if
you were staying out though
my accuracy is fading
huh just like some trials of the night
now
all right where the top of the Oh what
the hell is that oh this thing
my bad feeling about this
looks like it
well it seems that better sorting let's
check that out I guess later
swear which had rockets mistake sir
whoa what is that
those who stopped over here
walk along
collections appear together see pockets
on the side are next
gotta get the temple
copier
oh you jerk
what sucks as I can't actually see
again Zaheer
area
and getting others getting some yes
others hotdogs
they're not the same
yeah pulse grenade oh he should have
been doing that from the beginning
that's it
[Music]
okay oh I just wanted to see what it was
I thought I could jump over there those
dumb whoops
mistakes were made like a bad kind
bingo
no I'm gonna die again okay good that
was a one-shot jumpin hard isolating
these patterns overlaying onto the map
maybe it's over this is how we beat the
facts I've detected exchange a new
future I will inform us Cyrus wait a
defensive subroutine new reality
branches
[Applause]
oh that's really weird maybe that's why
he didn't wants to get to like come back
did we get back here the last thing I
remember we were in the EDC we found
that device and then WHAM oh I feel so
strange like someone's rearranged all
the furniture in the house except the
house is my brain all right look I never
thought I'd have to ask this but who
else has been inside my head accessing
memory course huh you've been busy
correction you've been busy without me I
don't know how I feel about that
wait a second gonna do it and you'll sit
here with me
and colleges big ones definitely thanks
look I can't decrypt those files or open
the gate we need backup
we need I chloride all right good idea
right
you're welcome back up wait why did I
just say that you guys go back to the
tower I was feeling we're going back to
the tower
ooh milestone update yeah
does this Erte yes it is it is I all
right
I'll turn in and then I'm gonna do one
more mission if it's not the last one
then that's just that oh yeah I turned
that oh you know what I did I turned it
off earlier because I was taking
screenshots I forgot to turn it back on
was fine
just one more is this deal she's short
potentially potentially short yes once I
I gotta take a few more screen ease some
stuff we got
assuming it'll load maybe maybe but not
I think it's because we're traveling
yeah image of the gun come on I love
this streaming thanks boy to whack ler
I said your name correct coming back to
the tower
darn you
any masterworks yet no long they don't
come out till next week
that's wealth so to this screenshot of
the scout rifle before I blew it up
[Music]
nothing we got anything at all straight
all right
it's back
oh wait we're gonna decrypt first
because we might have some well let's
see what we have just in terms of 3:05
just devastation complexes 3:11
karyotype so old stuff there but we can
infuse which is good should be like what
3:16 I can do that all that is required
is the right key
it's gonna make it the same actually so
we didn't get upgraded gloves I was
actually a bad drop we needed a home
we were three ten now yeah we needed a
man vigilant Guardian we may never quite
be as safe as we think
we live in dangerous
why so many dislikes I just could do
that it's destiny and people Oh some guy
found so bright always got three
hopefully we get a selfie ship nothing
unfortunate thank you for shopping
emotes no exotic see if there's a ship
look any different does it get the cool
like nope
this one looks kind of crazy I think
with a now that kind of this agility but
it's fine all right
is this DLC worth it as a solo player I
don't read much ooh that's kind of tough
probably not because he's so the raids
the same the only difference is the rate
layer and then campaign if you're
getting all the quality of life stuff
it's fine destiny died two years ago I
don't know about that
oh that guy's little 25 I refuse to
allow us to come this close to victory
and he's already gotten a few exotic so
the gear a sacrifice hatch tomorrow to
acquire exactly you know where no it's
not as does Osiris he will try to fight
it on his own
really I just came here that's it oh she
didn't even say anything or do anything
we literally just came to the tower to
talk there you have questions Omega
all right let's hope Omega is the last
one I don't have the selfie emote sadly
if I got it I would have definitely
equipped it do you guys have any idea
about the raid unfortunately not all of
her beep you pew I know as much as you
do I didn't go to the event either Aaron
and Kali went to the event but they
didn't see the raid layers anyway so
hopefully this is the last mission it's
been roughly three hours which is kind
of what I was told was the projected
time in terms of finishing it
Omega sounds like the last mission yeah
I know I mean like that's what I would
think to Bob but who knows
yeah it's kind of like these two backs
that just chill here I'll leave them
alone just yeah be very nice of me if I
just killed them there's this last step
well I don't know if he's actually lost
why not be lost you would think that
you'd be level 25 though by the time
they're done
oh hello
I am 24 almost 95 no so this could be
like um thinking about missions and how
they played out there's been a few that
I feel like have been pretty cool I like
that one where we're chasing that after
the Cabal and it had like lasers all
over the room kind of made you have to
deal with some other stuff but nothing
to like out of the blue that guy did
have a new weapon which is cool trying
to think of other enemy types though
that have been different they haven't
really always aesthetics whether it's us
or dissonance future is ending today
oh hi Cora what's up why couldn't you
just meet me here IRA C years of study
to find a way to open the gateways we
don't have years so
I know she can float down there thank
you I Cora later how did you get that
revolver this is better Devils this is
from PvP it's a very good hand cannon
though if you don't have one more weight
so you can go higher than level 20 yep a
new maximum level is 25 without sukira I
do whack Wow farewell well lacquer sorry
sorry it's huge
or C we can be camping in our state
worlds potentially can we see if it's
actually the last one but I'll do my
best
yes I'm gonna did out that way
[Music]
I've got one so hurt
maybe the ancient things on
Oh guys damn it I killed them too fast
no that was a new looking enemy or
looked like a new enemy ever seen that
they look like bones
and you guys down
[Music]
we're dragons all super a titbit are not
here what's up Ben bye good evening to
you all right I gotta be slower on the
trigger finger I guess case we see those
weird what I think our new enemies oh
they're just acolytes oh okay
then we're good thanks Connor French
that's a lot more boring and for the
longest time I didn't know you when I
found that revelation I was like holy
crap
I've been doing it wrong this whole time
oh sorry I have not watched that much
Dragon Ball super I haven't watched a
lot of Dragon Ball sometimes with kids
on this watch other anime though kind of
curious what that my hero academia game
is gonna be like from bent Namco would
you say the expression expansion is
worth picking up
I think that if you enjoy the game and
you have you want to keep playing more
of it to get one chance at this I think
it's worth it however if you're just
kind of wheat or destiny to to begin
with and you kind of fell off but you
didn't find it that interesting
I don't think buying this expansion was
like really help you want to play more
Sara Lee unless for some reason do you
have a big chase that you like well look
at this guy
I got hands
do you think maybe Siva will return I
think the next expansion is based around
my Steven or it had this evil logo so I
highly likely that it's
about this oh there was a whole nother
area
this place looks kinda cool though it's
freaking huge oh boy Oh
going on an adventure Osiris how does he
have event like the Fallen English
popular because he just creating like
simulation
I guess he doesn't want us to get to his
actual house which looks like it's over
there
get earned a body AR after the story
this is the last level okay
kind of figured I mean we are viewing
her okay those were acolyte
thank you to counter French for that one
for making me feel not crazy
good I mean there's a chance that it's
see the base the cybersecurity to the
bars to stop the Nazis all right they
are not here
so weird that he has to fall under this
control so weird that I can't be damaged
we have to do something to those towers
good news is he's not actually attacking
and it's a wave
were you super there when I decided
we're max-level now though or at least
like level one flight level we read not
quote we're like three 10 out of 335 and
I am modded up so
from the forest
as for as long as I can alright oh sure
let's take dollars defenses this is
crazy what are we doing
what is his defense oh so so so go there
guys
that seems kind of anticlimactic so now
we're gonna do another wave of enemies
and then do another slam and then the
final forum we'll fight fight
oh is he starting to fire stuff at us
though my accuracy is doing doing
where's that adderall when you need it
I don't know if you can get to 25 and
335 by playing just the base game
because it looks like these items are
based off
so porn again technically Osiris time
the shield
you got it desires
my bad I'm slacking
that I'm not sure first mom I can ask
though
as I ball strike it I know trying the
size people looking auto-rifle is a lot
harder than you came and on all right
now can we damage his ass yes
but his defenses are gone
all right so what's left cabal should
have been taken then I would have
probably Reagan has taken Saiyans
probably get away oh he's running away
shoot the foot
the mucus - kicks ass
glad you got lucky on the top there
no Penelope No
what
oh I'm sorry I had the help of the
greatest guardian of all time Osiris
where's your eyeball show it to me
get rekt hello give me back my ghost
what okay Adam dan says look so good
can't wait to play that was last mission
actually do you think there will be a
new speaker probably at some point oh
let's enjoy this
[Music]
[Music]
it's too boy
[Music]
next mind is destroyed and the path to
their dark future is done with it and in
case you were wondering our guardians
were amazing our Guardians her my
guardian guardian thief Osiris it's been
a very long time
too long my I was going to say students
but well that word is too small for you
now I've had other teachers time gained
a guardian who makes a habit of the
impossible who I'm proud to call a
friend the world has changed so has the
city
you could come back with me now my place
is here now we stop the vex this time
but many equations lead to the same
solution if they were ever to find
another
besides I predicted many things but I
never saw you now we have a future
[Music]
a pathway to the forest will be open if
you ever need to find me or if you want
to talk I'd like that
great galaxy stays friends again our big
hero over here and by the way you're
welcome
come little light we have infinite
realities to explore and all the time in
the world
[Music]
an icon called little white
all right brother brother Vance time
let's see what's up in the new
lighthouse yeah that was I don't know I
liked some of the missions if that was
all that I think that's the campaign
there I don't know
kind of wish we I don't know feel like
the story of Osiris could have been a
little cooler I guess
such is the way of krysta these are so
that was a campaign thank you guys for
tuning in for that part we're gonna
check out what up what is up with the
social space here wait I get to it do I
have to sit actually a different
destination or is it just part of this
oops
ooh he has another mission after the
fact so it looks like it could be a like
a it looks like one of those weapon
missions what's up buddy
so maybe we have to do that for
something potentially heavy trend the
weight of the world on your shoulders
come closer Titan oh you got em right
next to you we're almost kissing
pick one and written five works
exploring his wisdom and is a cool still
someone must record the signs I have
seen portents but direct my attention to
the infinite forest go probe its
mysteries and I'm sure Osiris will be
pleased honor if these are just the
token least enough stuff that you get
I think the mission is the Iowa Cyrus
gun yeah that that would make sense
I kind of like that home I kind of don't
like that it's a mobility resilience
home though it's like a balance tell
them I guess
and everything's mobility resilience
which is not what I'm a huge fan of I'm
all about that recovery resilience
damn I don't know which one to pick
they're all 311 Oh helmet we got to go
helmet because it is our weakest spot
right now so I think that's an easy easy
one for us here and let's check out his
faction rewards yep
oh so we got some couple new weapons
here sorry I'm gonna disappear again for
a second wait did you get this one
already yeah yeah it's rocket already
you have vertical orbit he does I'll
show you guys anyway this is vertical
orbits who's got triple tap here's a new
sniper high impact high range that
triple tap stability and handling seemed
kind of meh
and here's some of the old stuff oh they
got shaders though there is what is
supposedly kairos black
we look black to me got Cairo's bronze
that looks kind of ugly not feeling
these like mercury esque shaders
that one's okay I guess
all right
so he has 304 five gear looks like I got
a shader this thing I don't okay so he
gave me the mission right yes I'm back
because I don't know where to go
all right thanks better than stone I got
a complete an adventure alright we'll go
do that see you brother Vance dude I the
new monarchy is the way to go that's
what I'm gonna do for sure 100% once I
am able to I'm gonna pick up this coke
West because kill quests are the easies
I kind of like I kind of like the the
look of the set for the brother Vance
armor set but kind of a sad it's so much
like mobility resilience which is not
just set I favor
speaking of which I think I need to uh
there's a high bar targets
Murphy token ready from doing the Patrol
oh so by doing that little area that I
just did by clearing that I guess I
gotta try to trust all right as a token
looks like the public events
we're all gladiators
Oh water what a boss
while you get a lot more from those high
values got a minute our guard here looks
like he's got a COBOL guy in prison
it's like another oh it's another
high-value target if he doesn't have a
shield up but you guys drop a loot chest
another token take it
all right so this is the adventure right
ghost Guardian the max are running a
combat loop against fallen hostiles but
it won't be much of a test if we get rid
of all those simulated fallen graphics
go 30 I think this is all we had to do
right
hope yeah by a multi-step thing
if these readings are correct the
destination gateway is heavily protected
this Ben be also saying this is the
exotic weapon place not shocking but I
appreciate the info
hello boys and goodbye how many hours
till tazed MaxLite nah dude it's gonna
take a while like I said like the only
way I feel like it could happen like
relatively fast is if you just got lucky
on all three characters but then all
three character actually you could do
the milestones without finishing the
game so I guess technically maybe it
won't take super long I don't know
well like what do you really need to be
MaxLite for other than the Ray players
which we have no idea what the light
level requirement is I don't see them
being higher than 300 at least on normal
right because that's what the rate is so
can't be I don't know if being max light
level like matters as much anymore
except for if you're trying to do like
the prestige
red layer or something that will fight
matter
let me careless Am I I don't want to die
it's an acolyte max like stop playing
for months with Pete yeah solely up to
you if you want to do that at school
I think you're gonna as mention you want
to hold off your milestones and all that
stuff
all the other exotic weapon plus takes a
while so I wouldn't be shocked if this
takes like for like
or like five like parts to it
but if it's a high-level weapon like a
scout rifle or something even if the gun
itself is not good you were gonna want
to do it like as if it was like fur
Maite because then you could infuse that
and does something you actually like
like midnight or
don't forget there's gonna be selling
faded exotics this week thinking and buy
one on each other characters one exotic
so you're gonna get some exotics by the
end of the week as well he's also gonna
sell three of coins now prestige
Leviathan raid has a power level
recommended 330 yeah so I'll be pretty
hard raid keys are gonna reset alongside
checkpoints each week the keys used to
last is like I turned in a bunch last
night that's not gonna matter
basically the rail requirements match
what the previous ones were but with new
light it looks like you was in quicksand
for a second
disappearing kind yes lucky there
oh stop that
all right let's go
don't feelin these steps I got this cool
platforming right
do what you must stop the fall we should
save that just sorted that guy
and in doubt reboot oh servers shouldn't
be down but you do have to have the
expansion if you can't play the
expansion obviously I should have came
out for pc i believe already should have
came out like kind of the same time as
else and like weird server stuff that
people are having on xbox so should
hopefully be out PC as well but I
haven't tried myself so I can't
got two coins we adventure the runner
okay now what do we have to do oh
there's another adventure now is this
how you're getting me to do adventures I
guess it is we'll see how long this
takes in total
all right
like I should stop that
many courses are warring over a Treasure
Coast oh that's always data earlier
all right stop a cabal simulation so
we're going back in there I'm not sure
basically oh man are we doing three are
we doing like cabal and then we got to
do uh hi what's up here from your party
- you know I just kind of ignore stuff
I mean it's called the runner
[Music]
there's demons for this one diamonds
where the demons
yeah you can try to reset your system to
go to work
not sure Nevin on why that is the case I
could find out for you after this but I
can't detect right now in terms of your
questions I apologize
very heated now
uh there's a lot of legacy Oh God so a
lot of legacy subscribers as well
holiday I appreciate your kind words
also I feel like there's not as many
fans for destined to it by still enjoyed
and I still find that we're so could be
combination that but you know also I've
been streaming for like three hours
Damon's
this last guy yet
jerkface okay please don't kill me
with everything they could be doing in
the forest why would the vex choose to
focus so much effort on a solitary kemal
in a single simulation cabal is what it
carries may be critical to their
ultimate plans
and talk about get this is a way to get
you to do adventures I guess because I
know they're revamping it a little bit
the adventures and loss sectors but I
still don't think they're worth it I'd
rather just do heroic public events I
like how he can jump through what can I
jump through there's an illusion oh come
back dang it you can't be that fast
come back here
this guy's a cheater like he like jumped
up and then came back down oh that was
way past them whoops okay that's not the
plan and a little wasted resources there
I guess had to kill his lackeys to get
him to like show back up down below
pursue your target four out of five
check oh we have four more to go oh I'm
gonna die I'm still gonna die oh my lord
Wow
Wow is it hurt so bad
you would run
barricade yeah not now Oh what have I
died to that that was really silly
you run to
but now I see
get OPD
okay let's see what's inside oh this is
code for what looks like a phage
technology just like I screwed that up I
could kill them sooner I just had a
better grenades on them earlier like
that last one
all right now what now we gotta do bug
in the system give me this new gun
already
I wouldn't say these are the same okay
yeah that ventures are similar just in a
new environment yes that is speaking I
wonder how many people are actually
gonna be doing this heroic event or this
event because it's like if it yields the
same gear the only other reason to do
not sorry to do this one is to get the
coins I guess we could buy the brother
Vance yeah it does look pretty cool but
oops as mentioned I'm not a huge fan of
mobility resilience or yeah so I'm a PvE
kind of guy is the gun you're getting
the trace rifle one no it is not I think
it's the one that looks like the ax
Cyrus gun is my guess
yeah they're in the same spot I know
that like slightly farther away
detecting fix and hive signatures in the
forest might be worth checking out
yeah it's a hi everyone now all right so
technically there could be a fourth one
for just vex right because we've only
filled bawling and cabal all right won't
be shocked if there's four variations oh
boy
one o'clock this is definitely the last
we're doing on this gun
when it's blocked
now had to kill normal guys I guess Eric
just going to hole the studio hostage
yeah pretty much
oh you know what though at some point I
do need to give this up for Jake and
Nick they got a report
we'll see if we need to
I run this studio Bob I get to sort of
do what I want not really this order
besides we need to figure out how to get
the gun right
it's not clear - that looks like it
don't mind me you guys you guys just
fight it out and walk yourselves
what that cross you soon
that's [ __ ] I wasn't even low on
health that is so dumb whatever dental
where's our last bro salad having to
your brother's huh
aim though sick go kill the hive
ringleader yeah thanks open that in
Grand before I see I don't think it's
like it was higher than a 300 500 and
destroy their precious simulation
trysting city looking on
all right drop the charge that looks
like I got more hive we take apart the
more data we corrupt let me get the hive
part one of you
there's an ogre trade
come on drop more stuff on my grenade
shooting
yo I killed your buddies Wow
oh I see hi ow
moving over there
so streaming while you finish story yes
trying to do that quest to get the gun
so a longer Trek than I wanted it to be
but
keep going we finished the first wave
but the next data collection is
incomplete
same side
look city
Oh
Wow baby arms baby arms
stop
where is your boss anywhere that's what
do you got to do man
where is your leader hi guys the
lemonade
got it
I'm coming for you bro
but it nope
I was due
what Oh a barricade time that's it
I just subscribes his Tyler Brady Thank
You thanks what's up
where
I was too
Oh
dude you're a hacker thank you
[Music]
yes yes return to brother Vance brother
Vance I bet you there's one more step
who wants to bet me there's always step
please be the last step please we meet
again
Haroon we meet again you'll see me every
day pretty much unless I'm out of the
office I'm pretty much on all of these
kind of daily streams except for the
lobby hello sirs do you guys have any
new exotics looks like he's done the
heroic public event though
anyways when I awoke this morning the
portents were not good but then you
arrived 3:12 what just gives you an
Ingram no I kind of don't want to turn
it in though all right screw it for the
stream or the stream I will pop this
upon this
which is a lighthouse Ingram is to be a
story and as her own versions what did
that do did nothing I don't think guys
we got some new stuff I know it's good
to 12 foggy notion no one day a belfry
bounty that's a new weapon
I guess doesn't look like there's a no
there I mean all there was is heroic
tokens I think undertake one heroic
event John mercury per day which one was
the easiest one crap the first one I
don't know sure okay we unlocked a
heroic adventure I should know I know
that really it
I think that is I think we got duped
there is no gun guys
you just got legendary gear from
finishing the heroic adventure so well
we got duped guys no there's no reason
to do one more one more is just gonna
get us a legendary so I just want to say
thanks to everybody for sticking with us
for this long that was forcibly made a
Cyrus DLC for destiny too did the
campaign I got some milestones to get
through to kind of level up but the only
thing I didn't really show you guys was
probably the public event but you guys
can check that out but yeah hopefully
you guys got some exotics you want I got
one new one which is those boots they're
technically an destiny one they have a
slightly different modifier with
juggernaut but stay tuned again SWAT of
course we'll have more galleries of you
know different exotic weapons
we'll probably figure out how to do the
heroic public event and then we'll have
that video up as well so until next time
guys lobby tomorrow last Lobby tomorrow
so tune in for that gonna have some fun
Awards for the year just like our for
our for funsies ones they're not part of
the best of the year but tune in for
that until next time winner words in a
way no one else has I bet there's nobody
here who can quote his fifth homily
approach and be heard